chainsaw man is a story about a man
who's a chainsaw
they get that right chainsaw man is
possibly the hottest anticipated ip in
anime right now recently it doesn't seem
like shonen jump can miss when it comes
to their titles being guaranteed mega
hits jutsu kaisen the new kid on the
block that everyone seemed to talk about
demon slayer only broke every sales
record imaginable and completely
revolutionized anime movie tie-ins
forever spy x family i think more people
in the anime community watched this than
took showers and yet even with that it
feels like there's just as much hype for
chainsaw man even though it hasn't even
started airing yet 180 000 people were
waiting in the lobby for the new trailer
drop the trailer numbers have got
upwards of 17 million views on youtube
which is pretty much unheard of for a
new upcoming ip i mean these are the
kinds of numbers attack on titan final
season is getting and that's attack on
titan final season and judging from
these trailers alone this might be one
of the most beautiful things studio
mapper have produced i mean oh
just look at this
it's beautiful when this anime finally
drops it's pretty much set to take over
the anime community and further cement
shonen jump as the powerhouse of anime
and manga but
i'm not here to talk about chainsaw man
wait wait wait hold on a second hold on
i want to wait till the anime starts
airing before i attack with this
behemoth of a story because i've said
this a few times before but i haven't
actually read the chainsaw man manga yet
why i mean just look at this wouldn't
you want to experience this story for
the first time via anime if it ends up
looking this good what i have done
though is read pretty much everything
else the author has done taski fujimoto
is one of the hottest names in manga
right now and while chainsaw man is busy
taking over the world i wanted to take a
chance to talk about some of his other
works because after perusing i fully
believe that he might be one of my new
favorite manga artists of all time
reading this guy's work and seeing his
current path in manga i honestly think
we might be witnessing the journey of
one of the greatest manga artists of our
time yes burn this name into your memory
because this guy
could well possibly be
the new face of manga
everything he's touched without
exception is in my opinion worth the
read so if you're looking for something
to hold you over from that chainsaw man
hype this is the perfect place to look
let's start
with fire punch but before we jump into
fire punch i wanted to talk about my
friends over at bogsu who are today's
sponsor boxxu is a monthly subscription
service that delivers premium japanese
snacks and tea pairings straight from
japan to your door each boxing features
a new theme providing a gourmet journey
through japan every month and guys right
now i'm not gonna lie japan is
absolutely boiling in the summer heat
but on the bright side i finally get to
go to some summer festivals which is
this month's theme that's right you have
a chance to have your own mastery
festival this month because if there's
one thing you need to try out at summer
festivals it's the food and snacks and
boxu has got you covered they're here to
curate that experience just for you you
can find out more about matt's three
snacks in a helpful little booklet it
comes with each bok su along with the
best tea pairings to have with it now
one thing you've got to have at every
mastery is of course takoyaki and boxes
have given us some takayaki snacks right
here let's give this a taste shall we
oh that smells like takayaki god damn
oh is archu taste so much like takayaki
what the hell um we also got ourselves a
chocolate sand cookie let's have a taste
of this one as well
look at this i know i'm going to like
this already
oh that's a really refreshing snack
that's really good so if you want to
start your summer festival episode today
click the link in the description and
use code giggup15 for 15 off your first
purchase thank you to boxy for
sponsoring me today back to fire punch
fire punch is a story about a man who
punches things
with fire
[ __ ] nailed it it's the end of the
world the earth has frozen over into an
ice age plunging everyone into a
never-ending winter that has pushed life
to the edge plants won't grow animals
are dead and humanity is on the brink of
extinction thankfully there have been
some humans that have been blessed with
superpowers and perform feats of miracle
like our main character agni who's been
blessed with the ability to regenerate
under any other circumstance this would
be his opportunity to be a superhero but
in this barren wasteland there's only
one way his power can be useful
as an infinite food source arm after arm
he painfully severs his limbs for his
sister and village to feast upon so they
don't starve to death even though
there's little reason for anyone to keep
the will to survive and live on this
kind of way
this is how fire punch opens up its
world and introduces you to the story
that you're about to experience because
one day after encountering another group
of people who find out this village has
resorted to cannibalism to survive
another blessed human takes it upon
himself to cleanse the entire village
with his own powers by burning everyone
alive with a flame that cannot be
extinguished until the subject is dead
unfortunately for agni this means he's
been set ablaze with a flame that will
never stop burning him as he regenerates
faster than his body can turn to ash for
one whole year he could do nothing but
writhe around in pain constantly burning
to death but unable to ever die three
years pass until he can slightly move
around by chewing his tongue off to
distract him from the pain five years
before he learns to breathe with the
pain of the flame searing his lungs upon
every breath and only after eight years
of constantly burning is he fully able
to adapt to the pain and the first thing
he does is he makes a fist engulfed in
flames and goes
imma punch that [ __ ] who did
this to me yeah how's that for an origin
story oh look at this man with a little
spider bite was the little spider bite
painful did i give you a boo boo oh that
looks like a painful boo boo oh is the
widow baby sad cause his parents got
shot now he listens to my chemical wear
mask little baby don't be sad it's gonna
be okay [ __ ] that how about having your
friends and family burned alive in front
of you only to have your entire
existence be in constant searing pain of
being scorched to death every moment of
your life fire punch takes a super
powered superhuman stories you know and
completely flips it on its head it
reshapes and reframes what you think
having superpowers would be like by
dropping you into one of the most brutal
and unforgiving worlds i've seen in
manga got electric powers fantastic give
me a hammer so i can go around saving
the world like thor right nah actually
you know what you can be really useful
as a personal battery that people can
use to power their homes firepower
brilliant we're going through an ice age
right now so heat's the one thing humans
need so let's just strap you down so you
can become our personal industrial power
plant if you have powers you're not just
a human being but a natural resource
people need to expend in order to
survive and by god are people going to
survive by any means necessary this is a
world without hope and fire punch uses
this as a vehicle to dive right into the
deep end to showcase some of the worst
sides of humanity and the things people
will turn to in times of desperation
we've seen stories like this before but
fujimoto manages to present them in a
way that feels fresh and new it's a dark
deep introspective story that somehow
finds time to make some kick-ass action
along the way as well and even then he
finds his own way to do things like i
don't know why in basically every story
i've seen with superpowers there seems
to be this unspoken agreement that no
more than two people will have exactly
the same power and if two people in the
world do meet with the same power it's
just like oh hey you know i'm like the
token fire guy in the story so i guess
we've got to battle to the death and
stuff okay fire punches [ __ ] that let's
have a full-on slaughter fest with a
room full of wolverines who can
regenerate and see who comes out on top
people here know what kind of powers
exist and have adapted fighting styles
that play to their strengths and
weaknesses of the powers they go up
against to a regenerative body parts can
be a resource a weapon to be used to
give you an advantage agni gets impaled
[ __ ] chops his own head off mid-air
so he can regenerate faster and get back
in the fight chucks his arm at someone
and sets them on fire somehow in this
world gone mad fire punch still feels
like it's steeped in realism this is how
people would fight act and live if [ __ ]
like this actually happened in the real
world this is a story of nihilism in a
desolate world with little reason to
wake up and continue living where can
you even begin to find meaning in life
was there even one to begin with is it
possible to find hope in a place of
hopelessness it's also a story of a guy
who's been set on fire and punches
people it gives you such a unique
feeling reading it because there is one
big distinguishing trait i found with
tatsuki fujimoto's work
it's
it's [ __ ] weird within chapter one
agni's sister is like oni john do you
want to repopulate the world with me and
i was like oh fire punch
i didn't realize this was the kind of
fire we were going to be starting with
here but you know luckily before she
could light the flames off the incest
dumpster fire she just became one hey yo
one of the characters has an entire arc
where they want to make a movie and cast
acne as the main character which is like
okay another person meets a village
doctor and he seems like a swell guy he
wants to save all the children and the
dogs must be a good guy if he cares for
dogs and then out of nowhere he's just
like so
wanna [ __ ] my dogs and that's like some
of the more normal plot developments
that happen the second half of fire
punch is a psychedelic acid trip that
goes more off the rails the more pages
you turn and i'm definitely gonna need
another video to break this down because
i need you guys to know i can't be the
only one to know what it feels like to
be on fujimoto's wild ride if you think
you know the direction this story is
gonna take you're wrong every time you
think agni's gonna take one step forward
he takes two steps left and lever tapes
up this is not the kind of series that
will make any kind of sense in the
traditional way but if there's one thing
i will guarantee it's that it'll give
you an experience like none that you've
ever had before and that's something i
feel emanating out of all of this guy's
works he's someone who takes normal
convention and drop kicks out of the
atmosphere someone who isn't afraid to
throw in some bad [ __ ] insane things
into his work even if he knows the
general audience might not understand it
fire punch was a melting pot of raw
ideas from a talent that had yet been
refined it is far from the perfect manga
but through the unhinged madness i could
tell there was something special behind
this vision and i think fujimoto learned
a lot of lessons from this because his
future work would only grow to be more
polished while maintaining his unique
insane style obviously in chainsaw man
but also in his one shots namely look
back and goodbye airy
[Music]
most manga one shots you see are around
50-ish or so pages acting like an
extended manga chapter and yet this guy
somehow had the goal to do two very
notable one-shots one being 143 pages
and the other
being 200 pages that's not a one shot
that's an entire [ __ ] manga volume
which i believe in the mangaka world we
refer to as absolutely [ __ ] cracked
but it was in reading these two titles
that changed my perception of fujimoto
from just being a talented manga artist
to being an absolute genius both of
these one shots tell stories you may be
very familiar with look back follows the
life story of two manga artists that
become friends and goodbye areas about
dealing with the grief at the loss of a
loved one but they both take their own
very weird turn with their own weird
fujimoto flair that will take more time
for me to describe than for you to just
go ahead and read them so please just go
[ __ ] do that they're both available
in the shonen jump app and i guarantee
you're not going to find a better way to
spend 30ish minutes of your life what i
realized is that fujimoto has such a
unique style of storytelling that feels
almost intimate in a way the man has a
grasp of manga in a way others could
only dream and i think both these
stories fully display what makes him so
special this is what it's like seeing a
genius visual storyteller at work he
knows when to use dialogue and when to
shut up and let his panels do the
talking take this scene from look back
fujino is just a kid who draws manga for
fun her comics get published in the 4th
grade newsletter and everyone praises
her for it she's talented they say she's
the best there is they say there is no
one that could be better than her she
is a manga genius that is until one day
another person her age publishes their
art in exactly the same newsletter and
completely blows hers out the water hers
looks like an amateur scribble next to
this mystery person and everyone around
her makes her know it so unwilling to
take the l she practices day in day out
she works to improve her art before she
knows it it's years later and she's
looking at her new improved comic next
to the same person who's also gotten
drastically better in a way that she
could never even hope to reach convinced
there's no way she could ever compete
she gives up on manga and so time passes
and eventually she reaches graduation
age her teacher asks to deliver a
diploma that belongs to this mysterious
rival that she never met and after
reluctantly going along with it by
complete chance they meet turns out her
rival was another girl that was a
complete shut-in all this time that
focus on nothing but art she finds out
that her rival was actually jealous of
her and her storytelling skills and on
top of that was even a fan after asking
for an autograph the other girl the
rival the person that in fujino's mind
she could never hope to compete with
calls her a manga genius and then after
saying goodbye all you see her doing is
walking away and you see this
this
this
then you turn the page and
it's rare to see such a mastery when it
comes to visual storytelling you can
feel a wave of emotions shifting and
turning in a way that's normally
impossible to convey on a still page joy
excitement validation vindication this
didn't feel like i was reading a manga
it felt like i was watching a movie not
with rough storyboards but with real
actors conveying their subtle emotions
and that's the magic of his work his art
is able to portray such a range of
emotions and impact one panel could be a
silly character making a dumb face and
that the next could be a beautifully
haunting existential nightmare the kinds
of panel with such striking imagery that
it will be burned into your psyche for
years decades for your life to come it's
this ability to switch on and off at a
whim that makes fujimoto a master we are
just puppets on his stage with our
emotions tethered to whatever he wants
to express and all this is on full
display in goodbye airy which is one of
my favorite pieces of short fiction i've
ever read the manga focuses on a boy
trying to come to terms with his mother
passing away from cancer and he does
this by making his own movie that he
films with his own very weird and
twisted personality what makes this
special isn't just the story that's told
but the way manga is used as a way to
tell it almost every page in this manga
is split into four panels almost like
there are frames from a movie itself the
movie being made in this story sometimes
we are cutting to different scenes
sometimes it's a behind-the-scenes shot
and sometimes there are entire double
page spreads of almost the exact same
panel just so we can see subtle movement
and expression which means the few times
a page breaks this paneling formula it
impacts you in a new way i've never
really experienced it's different okay i
tried to find another way to say it
there isn't it just hits [ __ ]
different all right the narrative takes
you on a journey of what you perceive as
real reframing your perception as you
continue reading right up until the end
it weaves in and out of some perfect
blue-esque reality and we're here to
figure out whether we're watching a play
or whether we're watching real life
unfold the fourth wall isn't broken the
fourth wall is removed entirely and we
as an audience are wondering if it ever
existed in the first place this isn't a
manga this is an indie film that's been
playing inside of fujimoto's mind and
we've been lucky enough to get front row
seats at its screening somehow he's made
cinematic manga a thing this one shot
packs more emotion in these 200 pages
than most manga do in their entire run
there are twists there are turns there's
that same fujimoto weirdness that takes
you to a place you never thought the
story would go but at the end of it all
there is a message
loud and clear that culminates in a
final panel that blew
me away this was in the simplest of
terms a masterpiece if it was a real
screening i would have stood up and
given a standing ovation and that's why
i don't think i'm overstating it when i
say taski fujimoto could be one of the
future goats of manga it's rare that you
see such a raw talent in any field and
we are just now witnessing the start of
his journey i'm very surprised chainsaw
man blew up as much as it did telling me
his work would be something that appeals
to mainstream audiences would be about
as surprising as telling me that david
lynch is directing the next mcu movie
but at the same time i'm really glad
that it did because behind all this
craziness behind all the weirdness
behind all the bat [ __ ] insane ideas
there is a raw desire for expression you
can feel tatsuki fujimoto's pure passion
for storytelling bleeding out of every
single panel he does some of it may be
pretty out there but through it i sense
a conviction like no other from someone
who's so unwilling to compromise on his
vision even if it means having to stick
the middle finger to popular convention
and all this sets the stage for the
chainsaw man animated drop as the wider
world can get a glimpse of the face
of a new manga juggernaut of our time
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video i
am hype as hell for chainsaw man to come
out as everyone else is but i'm gonna
wait until it starts airing before i
consider making a video on it but with
that said thank you very much to alpha
sigma basil dysfunctional degenerate
elephant flabberwocky ivito jeff
levardos payne patchett pony stark water
guys vt and everyone else my patreon for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible again if you
haven't heard this might be old news now
but i am going on tour in north america
in the month of october and late
september if you want to have a chance
to see me and my fellow boys sea dog va
and joey the anime man live then go to
trashtaster.com to purchase your tickets
we are sold out in a bunch of cities
right now so please take this chance
while you still have it anyway though
that's it for me not many updates today
i've been giggling and i'll see you all
next time